Kylie Jenner shares a sweet video of  baby stormy the 20 year old mom took to  snapchat on Saturday to share this  close-up shot of her pretty girl looking  too cute with a flame face filter while  sucking on her pacifier a snap comes  just a day after Kylie celebrated her  daughter Stormies one-month birthday  with these adorable Mommy and Me pics on  Instagram  the reality star is slowly giving fans a  glimpse at her and boyfriend Travis  Scott's baby girl and the new parents  seemed to be going strong the 25 year  old rapper is even helping Kylie with  her new makeup line with Kylie cosmetics  he posted this pic to social media  showing off his swatching skills  jokingly writing new part-time job  Blaine oh yeah my D  [Music]